- La mort plane
au-dessus du village
de Saint-Élie-de-Caxton.
Fred Pellerin a écrit le conte
"L'arracheuse de temps" alors
qu'il était lui-même en deuil.
FRED PELLERIN,teteteur
- Moi, mon père est mort
subitement. Il était un être
très en santé, puis tout à coup,
il a penché sa tête puis
il était mort, une mort subite
puis... Fait que j'avais des
comptes à régler avec la mort.
Moi, j'ai eu un deuil de colère
quand mon père est mort.
- Salut, Fred!
- Salut!
- Une colère qu'il a sublimée
en beauté. Dans "L'arracheuse
de temps", Bernadette,
la grand-mère malade du petit
Fred, tente de le rassurer
sur son son n n lui racontant
une histoire qui s'est passée
au village en 1927.
CÉLINE BONNIER, comédienne
- Le conte a toujours servi
à ça, je pense, à nommer
justement les choses
qui étaient plutôt mystérieuses,
qui faisaient peur, pour
les enfants et pour les adultes.
- On retrouve toute une galerie
de personnages extraordinaires,
fantastiques, mais
extraordinairement vrais, etquq,
véhiculent de belles valeurs.
SONIA CORDEAU, comédienne
- Comment qu'il faut
s'entraider; pour moi, c'est ça
qui ressort le plus du film.
ÉMILE PROULX-CLOUTIER, comédien
- Qu'il nous laisse de la
fantaisie. En même temps,
il faut que ce soit des gens
qui sont réels. Fait que,
je pense que, la permission
que ça donne, c'est d'être
à la fois émouvant et cave.
(rire)
- Envoye! Essa d d d de jouer
à la sorcière.
- Au centre de l'histoire,
beaucoup de femmes fortes
et de convictions, comme
Bernadette, la grand
de Fred, que la comédienne
Jade Charbonneau incarne
du temps de sa jeunesse.
JADE CHARBONNEAU, comédienne
- Bien premièrement,
la grand-mère de Fred Pellerin,
dans le sens, c'est un cadeau
énorme. Puis c'est une jeune
femme qui a beaucoup de force,
qui est très s s s s téméraire,
très intelligente, puis
je trouve que ça fait du bien
de voir une jeune femme
comme ça au cinéma.
- Le réalisateur Francis Leclerc
parvient à transposer à l'écr
un monde merveilleux et
fantaisiste comme on en voit
rarement au cinéma québécois.
FRANCIS LECLERC, réalisateur
- Puis il y en a eu des
quand même au Québec qui
se sont frôlés au fantastique
ou à des films de genre.
Puis souvent, c'est boboche
parce papapapapapas d'argent.
Puis moi, c'était comme
une condition, c'est qu'on ait
les moyens de faire ce film-là
comme du monde.
ninininininiffez dans le mille,
monsieur le curé! Et voilà!
- On retrouve avec plaisir toute
la truculence des personnages et
de l'univers de Fred Pellerin.Pn
- Tu vas pas voir un show
d'humour, tu vas pas voir
un show de théâtre,
tu vas pas voir un drame,
tu vas voir Fred Pellerin.
- C'est qui ça, elle?
- "L'arracheuse de temps" prouve
que la mort d'un être cher
peut coïncider avec la naissance
d'une belle légende.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- Je déclare cet arbre coupable!
- J'ai-tu raison d'avoir